We have got a brilliant and very simple probability puzzle about a bull
and a bag. Well, maybe there's more than one board, but before that,
I want to tell you about this puzzle and the interesting about this puzzle,
which very few other puzzles you can say is it,
I know exactly the time it was invented.
It was invented by Lewis Carroll as he lay in bed on
the 8th of September, 1887.
How do I know that?
I know that because Lewis Carroll wrote a book of problems
that he called his pillow problems and he called them his pillow problems.
Because I don't know about you when you're trying to go to bed,
but Lewis Carroll, who I should really say,
maybe he doesn't even need to be introduced.
He's the guy who wrote Alice's adventures in Wonderland.
He said that when you are lying in bed,
sometimes you are victim to skeptical thoughts,
which seem for the moment to uproot the farmers' faith or blasphemous thoughts,
which dart unbidden into the most irreverent souls, and also unholy thoughts,
which torture with a hateful presence. The fancier that would Fain to be pure.
Okay. This is Lewis.
Carroll's introduction talking about all these terrible thoughts,
these naughty thoughts,
they're getting his head as a way to stop thinking these terrible things.
He goes against all these,
some real mental work is a most helpful
ally. In other words,
do puzzles because they stop you at night in bed just
before you're going to sleep.
Alex, Alex, Alex, you've just written a whole book about puzzles.
I have to say about you. Well, you're having unholy thoughts.
Um, I'm having incredibly,
incredibly unhealthy thoughts about all my puzzles all at the same time,
24 hours a day. Yeah.
So Louis Carroll invented this puzzle.
But he did invent this puzzle. And um, in the book,
he actually writes down the date by each puzzle of the evening or the night when
he ends each puzzle, which is why I told you the day, the first place.
So this puzzle is fantastic because it's one of those probability puzzles,
which means there's a kind of surprising, um, aha moment.
But it's incredibly simply stated what I have. I have a bag.
And in this bag, there is a ball.
You do not know the color of this ball. Exactly,
but we know it's either red or it's green and it can be either
one. In fact,
we're going to say that the probability is equal of a being red or green.
So in other words, the probability of this ball here is 50%.
Then the puzzle is just say, I have a bag with a 50% chance,
bull and red bull and sign it. And I got another red bull.
This ball is red with a hundred percent certainty. We know this ball is red.
I'm going to put it in the bank.
I'm then going to randomly take a ball out,
hitting the ranting bull that, Oh, it's red.
What is the probability that the ball that is still in the bag is red.
Okay. Now, if I was to do this many times, I would say, in fact,
I've got a ball it's red put again, take one out is red.
In other words, all I'm doing is just putting a red bull in.
I'm taking a red bull out, putting a red bull in taking a red bull out.
The surprising thing is that it changes the probability of the ball that's
inside. So what is that probability?
So when you just did it once, what is the probability, are you saying?
What's the probability, depending on how many times you do the experiment?
No, I'm saying what is the probability? When I do it,
once I have the ball, I put it in
To be very clear. I'm randomly taking one out.
It so happens that the rent one I ran, the release selected is red.
What are the challenges of this one? Still being read. Now, most people,
if they're not adept to probability problems, we'll look at this and think, huh?
You just put a Redwood in and we've taken a red one eyes.
How can it have changed the probability?
Because it seems natural that the one that's in there that we haven't
seen, how can its probability of change.
But if you unpick the wave of the question is phrased.
The probability of this one does change kind of as if by
magic. Do you want to think about it? And then we can maybe get solution.
Do I have some thinking time?
[inaudible].
We're back. We're back. Essentially with these probability puzzles,
we need to look at the sample space and kind of open up and look at the sample
space.
I it's almost spaces look at all the things that are equally likely to happen.
So we've got a bag inside it.
We know that either there is a red bull or Greenville with 50%
chance. One of the other tells a coin. So actually the sambal space,
we know that red bull and Greenville, this is equally likely.
Then I'm going to put the red bull in. So
this
is equally likely when I take one out,
either I'm taking this one art,
or I'm taking this one out,
or I'm taking this one out or I'm taking this one out,
but we know that the one I told you,
I selecting randomly these four ones that I take out are
happening equal likelihood.
We can eliminate the green one being taken out because I told you when I took a
random one out, it was red. In other words, I have either taken out this one,
this one or this one. If I took this one,
the one that is still in is red. If I took this one out,
the one that's still in Israel. If I take this one out,
the one that's still in his green, in other words,
still in for take this one out still in red.
If I take this one out, stood in red, I'll take this one out. Stood in green.
We have three different possibilities of a red one going at on two
of them, the one that's still in his red. So that's a two out of thirds,
66% chance. So I can redo it with my props.
This is red. This one, we don't know what it is.
It's like the red or green and 50% chance of being either one. I put one in,
I randomly take one out. Oh, I randomly take the red one out.
The chance of this being red has now jumped up from 50 to 66%.
This is by magic. Amazing. Congratulations, Carol.
You've just invented by yourself a fantastic probability puzzle.
But more than that at the same time contemporaneously, I don't think they knew.
Um, I was gonna say plastic, but
Well, Joseph patrol,
French mathematician invented a similar setup,
essentially the same math, which is called the Bertram box paradox.
And then a hundred years later it became the Monte hall paradox.
So this is actually, if you do the archeology of the Monty hall problem,
this is where it all began with Lewis Carroll in this Victorian nightcap
sitting in bed desperate, trying not to think blasphemous thoughts.
And he comes up with this puzzle.
It seems to me, Alex, the key piece of information here,
this moment where you took the green bowl out and revealed it to the audience,
you've raced that from existence.
You've erased that possibility from human existence and the fact you've tampered
with the universe in that way.
That's that's true. The thing is,
what we should have done is that I should really have taken one
out at random and sometimes I would get a green one,
but we've just leave those on the cutting room floor. Um,
so often with these probabilities,
we need to think about the problems is that it didn't happen.
I'm showing you a possible world,
but there are other equally likely possible worlds.
And the trick or the clue is that I say,
I randomly select one and take it out.
Lots of people won't actually register what that means because they will just
see this as only putting one in and taking one out.
But actually we need to realize that for every time I put one in,
take one out three times, I'll come up with a red,
but one time we'll come up with a green.
And we're just because you didn't see that green, we're just
forgetting about it.
But actually you need to take that green into account as being something that
could possibly have happened.
In fact, so when you said, I randomly take a ball out,
that's almost kind of like a little lies and that,
because it's not random because you're not showing me the times the
came out.
In retrospect is not random making a video, but that,
that is the slight, it's not lying,
but that's a slight smoke and mirrors of a lot of these probability problems.
That's right.
If you want to find out more about this kind of stuff,
then you really should check out brilliant today's episode sponsor in
particular, have a look at these courses on conditional probability in a,
see some familiar stuff there. And this one here,
perplexing probability is also a real classic.
Now all these courses have been handcrafted by the excellent people and
brilliant.
And I like to think of them being a bit like Nepalese mountain guides,
taking you on a journey, through learning,
but with all the inside knowledge and knowing all the best routes and the best
way to go to make the experience the best possible track.
They've got loads of courses. It's not just mathematics,
there's other science too, but a favorite thing of mine or their daily problems.
Here's an example, but you never know what you're going to get next.
Now you can go right now for free and have a look at brilliant.
But if you happen to sign up to their premium plan and get access to all the
good stuff, you can get 20% off that by going to
brilliant.org/number file. By the way,
you don't just have to sign it for yourself.
You can give brilliant as a gift to someone else.
Our thanks to them for supporting this episode. By the way,
if you want to check out Alex's puzzle book,
I'll put a link down in the description. I'll also put links to his other books.
He's done loads.